Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Es wird mal wieder gezeigt, auf die spanische Liga zu gucken. Und das tun wir heute hier im 101. Rasenfunk-Kurzpass mit Alex Truica. Der wird uns sagen, was ist eigentlich los in La Liga. Alex, sei mir sehr herzlich gegrüßt. Willkommen im Rasenfunk.
Hallo Max, danke für die Einladung.
Ja, ich freue mich sehr mit dir, einen profunden Kenner der spanischen Liga erwischt zu haben. Du konsumierst ziemlich viele Spiele jedes Wochenende.
Ja, das ist mein Hobby, meine Leidenschaft. Ich schaue immer sehr viele Spiele, aber tatsächlich nicht nur Spanien, sondern auch Bundesliga und die Premier League.
Ach ja, die Premier League, das ist noch mal was. Weißt du, wenn man so viele Bundesligaspiele guckt wie ich, dann hört sich das, das fühlt sich für mich mal so an wie Fernweh, wie es sich für andere Leute anfühlt, wenn jemand von seinem Karibik-Urlaub erzählt. So ist das, wie wenn mir jemand erzählt, ich gucke ja sehr viel Premier League und immer die Top-Spiele in der Serie A und La Liga, dann denke ich mir, ach, wenn ich dafür noch die Zeit hätte. Naja, aber deswegen habe ich ja Gäste wie dich, dass du mir erklären kannst, was los ist in der spanischen Liga. Wollen wir mal reingehen, vielleicht mit dem wichtigsten Thema oder dem, was auch hier in Deutschland natürlich angekommen ist. Real Madrid, da läuft es nicht so wirklich. Tabellenplatz 6 und nach dem 1 zu 5 im Klassikoo den Trainer gewechselt. Lopetegui ist nicht mehr. Wie ist da der Stand? Wer ist gekommen und warum musste Lopetegui gehen?
Ja, im Endeffekt musste er gehen, weil er seinen Ruf und quasi seine Karriere schon bevor er überhaupt angefangen hat, beschädigt hat, also bevor er bei Real Madrid angeheuert hat, weil das einfach diese diese chaotische Sache bei der WM war, dass er als spanischer Nationaltrainer quasi Tage bevor die WM begonnen hat, zurückgetreten ist oder rausgeschmissen wurde, weil er den Job bei Real Madrid wollte. Und im Endeffekt hat er da schon seine Reputation so beschädigt, dass das einfach auf die Liga und auf seine Karriere bei Real Madrid jetzt nachhalte.
Ehrlich, hat es auch bei Real? Also, weil die könnten ja sagen, hey, wir haben ja einen tollen Trainer bekommen. Bei Real Madrid ist es ja eher, weiß nicht, also er konnte sich voll auf diese Aufgabe konzentrieren, hätte ich jetzt gesagt.
Ja, aber du musst so sehen, viele spanische Nationalspieler sind natürlich auch Spieler von Real Madrid und sein Abgang war natürlich so, ja, ist so blöd verlaufen, dass er da quasi den Respekt der Nationalspieler, auch den in Diensten Real Madrids bereits verloren hatte, noch bevor er überhaupt bei Real Madrid unterschrieb, weil im Endeffekt das Thema war ja, er hat den Rubiales, den Chef der spanischen Föderation, hat er nicht in Kenntnis gesetzt, dass er bei Real Madrid anheuern wird und ja, sein Abgang quasi war dann unter schlechten Vorzeichen und stand halt quasi, seine ganze Karriere bei Real Madrid stand unter einem schlechten Stern und natürlich haben die Spieler von Real Madrid, die Nationalspieler sind dann dementsprechend bestimmt auch den Respekt vor ihm ein wenig verloren.
Das muss sich für Sertor Ramos zum Beispiel angefühlt haben wie ein Ellenbogenschlag ins Gesicht, von dieser Seite kennt er das ja gar nicht und die WM verlief ja auch nicht besonders erfolgreich für Spanien. Also dass das ein großes Thema ist, war klar, aber wie war denn das ganze sportlich ausgestaltet? Also der Beginn war ja gar nicht so schlecht. Die letzte Folge zur spanischen Liga haben wir nach dem vierten Spieltag aufgezeichnet und da hatte Real damals drei Siege und einen Unentschieden und nur im Supercup hat man gegen Atletico nach Verlängerung verloren gehabt. Was ist denn danach passiert? Woran hat es denn sportlich gemangelt?
Also grundsätzlich muss man sagen, es sind viele, viele Probleme, die da aufeinandertreffen. Zum einen natürlich der Abgang von Ronaldo, der wurde nie kompensiert. Ich glaube auch, dass Real Madrid das fürchterlich unterschätzt hat, wie wichtig er für die Mannschaft ist.
Kann das wirklich sein?
Ja, offenbar hat man es unterschätzt, denn es wurde ja nur Mariano von Lyon geholt als Stürmer, aber der ist Back-up für Benzema, sprich das ist ja nicht der 1A-Ersatz von Ronaldo gewesen, sondern sie wollten den Abgang im Kollektiv kompensieren mit Benzema, mit einer größeren, wichtigeren Rolle für Bale, mit Asensio auf dem linken Flügel, mit Isco, der Offensiver spielt. Also wie gesagt, im Kollektiv wollten sie es auffangen, aber offensichtlich könnten sie es schlicht nicht auffangen.
Ja, und ja auch die Defensive nicht ganz so sattelfest. Also 16 zu 14 Tore, das heißt nur 16, Anführungszeichen, erzielt. Barcelona hat fast doppelt so viele mit 31 und eben 14 kassiert. Und das wirkt sich dann eben, wenn du so wenige Tore schießt, deutlicher aus. Was ist denn das für ein Fußball gewesen, den Real gespielt hat? Also an die Ronaldo-Zeit können wir uns ja alle erinnern. Das war sehr flügellastig und hat aber wesentlich halt damit zusammengehängt. Bringen den Ball irgendwie zu ihm, eigentlich egal ob in der Luft oder am Boden. Und er wird zu seinen Chancen kommen und sie sehr wahrscheinlich auch nutzen. Hat sich das unter Lopetegui schon gedreht?
Das hat sich ein bisschen gedreht, aber ich möchte noch kurz was zur Defensive sagen, die du natürlich angesprochen hast. Die Offensive ist natürlich ein Problem, dass die Ronaldos Tore fehlen. Die Defensive ist das andere Problem. Also Real leidet auch unter einer Kater-Stimmung nach der WM. Besonders Varane, der natürlich die WM gewonnen hat mit Frankreich. Und aber auch Ramos sind derzeit in fürchterlicher Form. Dadurch fehlt die Stabilität in der Abwehr. Aber auch Modric, Kroos und Casemiro, die das Mittelfeld natürlich stabilisieren, die den Taktstock schwingen, auch die sind in schlechter Form. Dadurch wackelt das ganze Konstrukt. Also nicht nur vorne stimmt es dann nicht, weil die Tore fehlen. Im Mittelfeld stimmt es nicht, weil die Stabilität fehlt. Und in der Abwehr sind sie halt auch nicht gut. Und du siehst, alle drei Mannschaftsteile sind betroffen. Und das führt dann dazu, dass man unter anderem daheim schlechte Ergebnisse erzielt, dass man keinen guten Fußballspiel, keinen sicheren Fußballspiel –natürlich hat Lopetegui jetzt, um auf das andere Thema zu kommen –versucht, der Mannschaft mehr Stabilität zu geben, mehr Ballbesitz, dass sie aktiver mit dem Ball spielen. Sie haben ja unter sich dann eher gern mal gekontert, gern mal Superheldenfußball gespielt, wenn man das so sagen will. Also sich darauf verlassen, Ronaldo wird schon was machen, der Modric wird schon oder große werden schon einen Pass auf die Flügel schlagen. Und Lopetegui hat dann den Ansatz, dass das Kollektiv besser wird, dass der Fußball fluider wird. Aber wie gesagt, wenn die Einzelspieler in schlechter Form sind, wenn die Mannschaftsteile in schlechter Form sind, dann leidet der ganze Fußball drunter.
Das kulminierte dann alles im Klassik, der mit 1 zu 5 in Barcelona verloren ging. Denkwürdiges Ergebnis und natürlich allein wegen der Bedeutung des Spiels konnte man dann schon ahnen, jetzt wird es ganz eng für Lopetegui. Wie geht es denn jetzt weiter bei Real Madrid? Santiago Solari ist jetzt erstmal der Nachfolger geworden.
Genau, es gab Gerüchte, dass Pérez, der Präsident von Real, einen harten Hund haben will, jemanden, der durchgreift als neuen Trainer. Und da gab es angeblich Verhandlungen mit Antonio Conte. So ähnlich wahrscheinlich. Aber da stellte sich dann Ramos, der natürlich mehr als nur ein Kapitän ist mittlerweile, der hat schon sehr viel zu sagen bei Real Madrid. Und da stellte er sich dann vor die Mikrofone und hat gesagt, dass man sich Respekt erarbeiten muss. Den kann man nicht auferlegen. Also das wurde so interpretiert, dass das quasi ein Seitenhieb gegen Conte ist, der ja sehr viel als alter Hund gilt, der alles unter Kontrolle haben will, den Spieler kontrolliert.
Da ist er rhetorisch aber subtiler als auf dem Platz. Also den Seitenhieb, da muss man schon ein bisschen Interpretationsleistung.
Genau, aber tatsächlich haben das die Medien so interpretiert, dass Ramos gegen Conte sein soll oder vielleicht sogar der Dressing Room. Er ist nicht wirklich zufrieden mit Conte als neuem Trainer oder als gehandelten Trainer.
Coach Varr wurde da ja auch immer genannt, der angeblich unter anderem wegen seines Verhältnisses zu Conte von Chelsea zu Real gewechselt ist und der hätte sich natürlich bedankt, wenn ihm jetzt der Trainer hinterherkommt.
Genau, und so hat man dann quasi von dieser Personalie Abstand genommen, sei es von Conte Seite, sei es von Real Madrid Seite, ist schwer zu sagen, aber auf jeden Fall wurde dann der Coach der zweiten Mannschaft, Santiago Solari, befördert und jetzt im Endeffekt auf unbefristete Zeit.
Okay, und das heißt, wenn es jetzt weiter erstmal so erfolgreich läuft, also die Spiele seitdem 4 zu 0 in Melilla gewonnen, ist jetzt auch nicht so Melilla wahrscheinlich, der Max spricht natürlich gleich aus wie so ein dummer Deutscher, dann gegen Valladolid zu Hause 2-0 gewonnen und jetzt in Pilsen mit 5 zu 0, das heißt, die Ergebnisse haben gestimmt seitdem, spielweise nicht immer, bei Valladolid habe ich so ein bisschen was mitbekommen, aber das sieht erstmal so aus, als würde das mit ihm so weitergehen.
Ja, wie so oft ein Trainerwechsel kann kurzfristig Erfolg bringen, einfach nur, weil frischer Wind weht in der Kabine, weil neue Besen müssen nicht auf Strecke gut kehren, aber zumindest am Anfang kehren sie manchmal ganz gut, zumindest den alten Staub aus der Kabine, wenn man so will. Und tatsächlich, dadurch, dass Solari ein ehemaliger Spieler ist, ehemaliger Real Madrid-Spieler sogar, gibt es da eine gewisse Parallele zu Zidane, der natürlich diese Aura hatte, diese Respektperson war aufgrund seiner Karriere als Fußballer. Und wie gesagt, die Parallele zu Solari ist, beide haben bei Real Madrid gespielt, hatten eine gute Karriere und beide waren zu Anfang Trainer der zweiten Mannschaft. Ja, das kann gut kommen, zumindest am Anfang, einfach, dass die Dressing Room mehr hinter Solari steht. Die ersten Ergebnisse sehen ja gut aus.
Genau, taktisch hat sich nämlich, wenn man sich die Ausstellung anguckt, nicht so wirklich was verändert. Das heißt, da muss es andere Gründe geben. Also gucken wir, wie Real sich weiterentwickelt. Aktuell Tabellen Platz 6 und schon 7 Punkte Rückstand auf Barca, die mal wieder von ganz oben grüßen, von Platz 1. Sind die so dominant wie immer oder hat sich auch da ein bisschen was verändert im Vergleich zur letzten Saison?
Ja und nein. Also sie sind dominant wie immer, aber in der Abwehr anfälliger als sonst.
Auch schon 14 Gegentreffer, aber halt 31 geschossen, das hilft.
Genau, die Abwehr ist brüchiger als vorherige Saison. Sie kassieren mehr Gegentore, sie lassen aber auch mehr Torschüsse zu. Und interessant ist, dass die Gegner weniger Torschüsse pro Tor benötigen. Die Bayern können ein Lied davon singen. Jeder Schuss ist ein Treffer zuletzt unter Neuer. Ich glaube, die letzten drei Torschüsse waren alle drin bei Bayern.
Ja, aber jetzt gegen AEK durfte er jetzt einen halten. Also diese ganz schlimme… Ja, genau, da haben sie auch alle gejubelt.
Also ganz so schlimm wie bei Bayern ist es natürlich nicht. Aber tatsächlich brauchen die Gegner weniger Torschüsse, um ein Tor zu erzielen. Letzte Saison habe ich nachgeschlagen, waren es ungefähr 15 Tore bis Barca ein Gegentor kassiert. Und jetzt ist die Hälfte. Also sieben Schüsse führen zu einem Tor. Man kann auch sagen, da kommt ein bisschen Pech dazu, weil normalerweise gleicht sich das ja aus. Das bleibt ja selten so. Aber trotzdem, sie lassen mehr Torschüsse zu, sie sind fragiler. Und das hat tatsächlich auch mit dem System und mit Usman, dem Ballet zu tun. Ja, in der letzten Saison fiel er ja weite Teile der Saison aus. Dadurch war Barca gezwungen, 4-4-2 zu spielen. Was ihnen einfach mehr Stabilität gegeben hat. Sie standen im Mittelfeld dichter, logisch. Einen Spieler mehr im Mittelfeld. Messi konnte offensiver spielen. Messi spielte mehr als hängende Stürmer spitze im Zentrum. Letzte Saison ließ sich aber bei Ballbesitz teilweise auch zurückfallen ins Mittelfeld, weil er ja gerne die Bälle fordert. Sprich, sie haben ja zuweilen dann sogar mit fünf Mittelfeldspielern geführt, also gespielt, situativ. Und jetzt ist Dembélé zurück. In seinem zweiten Jahr muss er natürlich, muss er sich beweisen, darf sich beweisen und wird aber natürlich auch eingesetzt, weil er hat ja so viel Geld gekostet, er kann ja nicht auf der Bank schmoren. Sprich, Barca spielt jetzt wieder 4-3-3 und das ist einfach etwas anfälliger. Also es gibt weniger Absicherung mit Messi, Suárez und Dembélé. Das 4-3-3 ist halt etwas riskanter. Es gibt weniger Absicherung, weniger Abwehrarbeit gegen den Ball, vor allem wegen Messi und Dembélé, die nicht dafür bekannt sind, dass sie mit zurückarbeiten. Dann kommt dazu, dass das Mittelfeld nicht der schnellste ist. War es natürlich noch nie. Aber es kann natürlich entlöst werden gegen Umschaltsituationen, gegen Konter, weil Artur, Coutinho, Raketic und Busquets einfach nicht die schnellsten sind. Sprich, wenn der Gegner schnell umschaltet, sind sie da einfach anfällig. Ja, Piquem in der Abwehr wird nicht jünger und war noch nie der schnellste. Und das andere Problem ist, Sergi Roberto, der gerne mal Rechtsverteidiger spielt, ist kein gelernter Rechtsverteidiger, sprich auch er hat Defizite in der Abwehrarbeit. Dann fiel Umtiti verletzt aus. Neuzuang Lengley macht sich zwar gut, aber kriegt eigentlich mehr Spielzeit, als er normalerweise bekommen würde. Und ja, so kommt eins zum anderen und so ist einfach die Mannschaft anfälliger als letzte Saison.
Aber es reicht ja trotzdem. Also nur eine Niederlage, das war gegen Leganes im Auswärtsspiel am sechsten Spieltag. Ansonsten 7 Siege, 3 Unentschieden und eben den komfortablen 7-Punkte-Vorsprung auf Real und 3 Punkte dann auf die direkten Verfolger hinten dran. Also würde ich das jetzt dann von außen betrachtet verkürzen, indem ich sage, auch unter Einbezug der Champions League-Ergebnisse, wo man 4-0 gegen Eindhoven, 4-2 gegen die Spurs, 2-0 gegen Inter und dann jetzt eben 1 zu 1 gegen Inter jetzt im Rückspiel gespielt hat, es reiche noch.
Es mag Jammern auf hohem Niveau sein, aber es liegt halt auch daran, dass Real und Atletico beispielsweise schwächeln, mehr schwächeln als man es gedacht hätte. Sprich, wenn die beiden bessere Ergebnisse erzielt hätten, wäre Barca vielleicht gar nicht erster, weil sie haben ja zwischenzeitlich vier Spieler nicht gewonnen am Stück Barcelona. Ja, und ja, es ist deswegen krass, weil es zu so einem frühen Zeitpunkt der Saison ist, also wir haben erst den 11. Spieltag und vier davon am Stück haben sie schon nicht gewonnen. Also das war eine sehr frühe, unerwartete Schwächeperiode, die einfach kein anderer ausnutzen konnte. Und auch deswegen sieht es jetzt natürlich rosiger aus, als es eigentlich war. Aber ein anderer Grund, warum es jetzt wieder rosiger aussieht, ist tatsächlich, weil Werder wieder auf ein 4-4-2 umgestellt hat, oder beziehungsweise so ein 4-4-2-Hybriden. Beim Auswärtsspiel in der Champions League, bei Tottenham Hotspurs, hat Coutinho quasi einen falschen Flügelstürmer gegeben. Sprich, mit Ballbesitz war er eher Flügelstürmer, aber gegen den Ball war er Mittelfeldspieler, linker Mittelfeldspieler. Sprich, da hat er ihm mehr Stabilität gegeben. Das war auch meiner Meinung nach eines ihrer besten Spiele, vor allem angesichts des Gegners auswärts bei den Spurs. Das war schon eine sehr, sehr gute Leistung. Aber es hatte auch mit der Systemumstellung zu tun. Und jetzt gab es noch eine weitere kleine Systemumstellung, wenn man so will. Durch Messis Armbruch spielen jetzt Coutinho und Raffinja auf den Flügelhalbpositionen, interpretieren sie aber eher als Mittelfeldspieler. Sprich, man kann sogar sagen, teilweise ist es ein 4-5-1 mit Suárez im vordersten Front. Und links und rechts Coutinho. Und auch das 4-5-1 gibt ja natürlich viel mehr Stabilität. Ja, gegen den Ball sieht das jetzt besser aus, weil einfach vor allem Rafinha viel arbeitet, weil er ja gelernter zentraler Mittelfeldspieler ist. Und mit und gegen den Ball ist das jetzt einfach sicherer, mehr Kontrolle.
Also wir sehen, es gibt viel zu beobachten bei Barca, auch wenn das Blick auf die Tabelle gar nicht so sehr offenbart. Was aber der Blick sofort zeigt, ist, dass da eine Mannschaft direkt hinter Barcelona liegt, mit der man nicht unbedingt gerechnet hätte, nämlich Barcelona, Espanyol in dem Fall, drei Punkte hinter Barca, auch erst zweimal verloren, drei unentschieden. Das heißt, dann kommt man eben bei so einer guten Leistung heraus. Was ist denn mit Espanyol los?
Die haben einen neuen Trainer. Das ist mit denen los. Also das ist tatsächlich der wichtigste Neuzugang. Ihr Trainer ist Rubi. Der führte das kleine Huesca von der 2. Liga in die erste, zum erstmaligen Aufstieg in die Primera Division. Und dann kam Espanyol und das ist sein Jugendverein. Und dann hat er tatsächlich seinen Vertrag. Genau, dann hat er seinen Vertrag mit Huesca aufgelöst, weil Espanyol natürlich nicht nur sein Jugendverein ist, sondern natürlich auch eine richtig gute Chance für ihn. Genau, und er, weil Rubi muss man dazu sagen, er hat in der Akademie Espanyols gespielt, er war Trainer ihrer zweiten Mannschaft und hat eben jetzt die Chance, sein Jugendverein zu trainieren und macht das richtig, richtig gut. Das muss man schon sagen, also die sind sehr heimstark, 5 Spiele, 5 Siege, 8 zu 1 Tore. Kann man nicht meckern, ein Gegentor in 5 Spielen nur. Sie haben die zweitbeste Abwehr der Liga hinter, wem sonst, Atletico Madrid natürlich. Und ja, genau, sie spielen als Mannschaft einfach viel, viel besser. Also er ist der Grund, warum Espanyol so weit oben steht.
Und haben ja auch einen ganz interessanten Kader, also sehr, sehr viele Spanier und so eine wilde Mischung aus sehr, sehr jungen und sehr erfahrenen Spielern. Jetzt weiß ich als jemand, der das Ganze jetzt nur so aus der Fahne betrachtet, nicht wer wie oft davon aufläuft. Was für ein Fußballspiel denn Espanyol und wofür stehen die dann, auch wenn sie auf dem Platz stehen jetzt, die Elf?
Also Rubi lässt 4-3-3 spielen. Ballbesitz und Positionsspiel sind ihm wichtig. Dadurch werden sie, wie gesagt, aktiver als Espanyol in den letzten Jahren war, wo sie eher eine reaktive Mannschaft waren. Sie spielen jetzt, wie gesagt, mehr auf Ballbesitz. Und weil du die Spieler erwähnt hast, die haben meiner Meinung nach vier Schlüsselspieler. Darauf kann man es vielleicht runterbrechen. Das ist zum einen der Stürmer Borja Iglesias. Der kam vor der Saison für 10 Millionen von Celta, hat aber bei Celta gar nicht gespielt, weil er in die zweite Liga ausgeliehen hat. Er hat 22 Tore für Saragossa geschossen. Den hat sich Espanyol 10 Millionen kosten lassen. Und er hat jetzt in elf Spielen schon sechs Tore geschossen. Also ein Stürmer, der dir Tore schießt. Der ist schon mal ein Punktgarant in der Regel.
Vor allem bei 15 insgesamt erzierten Toren ist das auch schon ein deutlicher Anteil.
Genau, also der ist ein Schlüsselspieler. Dann die Mittelfeldzentrale. Sergi Darder, der war unter anderem bei Lyon, wurde jetzt fest verpflichtet. Und Marc Roca, das ist ein 21-jähriger, ganz interessanter Mittelfeldspieler. Er spielt im defensiven Mittelfeld. Er ist ein typischer spanischer defensiver Mittelfeldspieler. Also sehr umsichtig, sehr passsicher. Er besticht durch Positionsspiel und tatsächlich durch Intelligenz. Der weiß, sich gut zu bewegen, gut den Ball zu verteilen. Und genau, im Zusammenspiel mit Sergi Darder, der vor ihm spielt, ist das ganze Zusammenspiel von Espanyol sicherer, besser geworden. Und genau, das ist im Zentrum quasi, sind zwei wichtige Leistungsträger. Und in der Innenverteidigung, denn ich habe ja angesprochen, sie haben die zweitbeste Abwehr, ist eine Entdeckung der Saison. Innenverteidiger Mario Hermoso, der Just jetzt erstmals von Luis Enrique für die spanische Nationalmannschaft nominiert wurde. Der wurde bei Real Madrid wo sonst ausgebildet, wo so viele Spieler, die bei mittelklassigen Clubs spielen, immer ausgebildet werden. Er bekam jetzt eine Chance, in seiner zweiten Saison bei Espanyol wurde jetzt unter Rubi Stammspieler und spielte, das muss man wirklich sagen, eine bärenstarke Saison und ist auch mit ein Grund, warum die Abwehr so sicher ist.
Mensch, super. Das sind jetzt mit Hermoso ein 23-jähriger, Rocca 21, Darder 24 und Iglesias 25. Also auch wirklich Spieler mit Perspektive. Hast du denn dann auch Hoffnung, dass das ein nachhaltiger Trend ist bei Espanyol? Das ist ja durchaus was Erfrischendes, wenn man mal andere Mannschaften auf Platz zwei rumkräuchen sieht in La Liga oder werden die normalen Mechanismen vermutlich auch da wieder greifen, dass halt dann irgendwann der Sprung zu Barca, Atletico oder Real kommt und dann fängt man ein bisschen wieder von vorne an bei Espanyol.
Ja, sowas ist natürlich am 11. Spieltag schwer einzuschätzen, aber tatsächlich von den Überraschungsteams der Saison, wir werden danach ja zu Alaves kommen, dem zweiten großen Überraschungsteam, würde ich Espanyol am ehesten zutrauen, dass sie unter den, sagen wir mal, Top 8 landen. Also weil tatsächlich dieser Kern sehr interessant ist, wie du es gesagt hast, vier junge spanische Spieler. Ja, das ist eine sehr interessante Mannschaft, der Trainer ist interessant. Tatsächlich würde ich es denen zutrauen, am ersten noch im oberen Drittel zu landen, also sprich, weiterhin eine gute Rolle zu spielen.
Ja, da kann man ja mal gespannt sein, was Espanyol so macht. Es ist auf jeden Fall erfrischend, mal darüber zu sprechen. Und das Duell mit Barca kommt ja noch. Anfang Dezember hat man das erste Mal als Heimspiel. Empfängt man dann den anderen Club aus Barcelona. Etwas weniger überraschend obendrein auf Tabellenplatz 3 mit vier Punkten Rückstand der FC Sevilla. Mir vor allem als Europa-League-Sieger bekannt, wem eigentlich auch nicht. Ist da etwas Besonderes an dieser bisherigen Saison bei Sevilla, dass sie auf den dritten Platz landen? Oder würdest du sagen, eigentlich eine normale Saison und dann halt zuträglich das Atletico und Realgerade schwächeln und so kommt dann der dritte Platz raus?
Also wie bei Espanyol ist auch bei Sevilla der Schlüssel zum Erfolg der Trainer. Auch der ist neu, Pablo Marín. Der war vorher bei Girona und hat die erst zum Aufstieg geführt und dann zum sensationellen zehnten Platz, wobei sie sogar sehr lange an den Europa League-Plätzen geschnuppert haben. Also bis, ich glaube, drei, vier, fünf Spieltage vor Schluss waren sie auch ein Europa League-Aspirant, was ja sensationell ist für Girona. Man kann es so sehen, Girona ist im Endeffekt so was wie Heidenheim oder Sandhausen. Also mit so einer Mannschaft den Aufstieg zu schaffen, ist schon sensationell. Aber sie dann in Europa League-Reichweite zu führen im ersten Jahr ist umso erstaunlicher. Genau, und er wurde jetzt von Sevilla abgeworben. Und auch er, also auch bei Sevilla ist er wie gesagt der Trainer, der Schlüssel. Er spielt ein sehr interessantes 3-4-3, sieht man ja so eher selten. Mit hohem Pressing, hoher Intensität, viel Aufstärke, das Kollektiv steht überall, die Organisation und Balance ist ihm sehr wichtig. Und er scheint zu funktionieren. Also die Mannschaft nimmt das an und er macht einen richtig guten Job.
Ja, das ist schon interessant, wie die Rolle der Trainer in diesen internationalen Kurzpässen oftmals anders bewertet wird, als wenn wir über die Bundesliga reden. Ich weiß dann immer so gar nicht, ob das daran liegt, dass man sich bei der Bundesliga eben per se ein bisschen besser mit den Details auskennt und dann nicht beim Trainer aufhört, wenn man sagt, warum spielt jemand gut, sondern da geht es eben weiter mit, ja, der linke Verteidiger hat auch gerade eine gute Phase. Oder ob das tatsächlich auch ein unterschiedlicher Blick auf Trainer ist. Also gerade bei der Serie A habe ich mir das auch schon häufiger gedacht, wenn ich da mit Christian Bernhard darüber gesprochen habe. Gibt es denn auch Spieler, die bei Sevilla herausragen aus diesem viel laufendem und gut arbeitendem Kollektiv?
Also grundsätzlich, Eva Barnega war ja schon letzte Saison. Der Schlüsselspieler ist es jetzt auch wieder. Er spielt in einer etwas zurückgezogener Rolle diesmal unter Marquine. Er ist eher im defensiv-zentralen Mittelfeld, wohingegen er letzte Saison eher auf der Zehn war, eher aktiver und offensiver gespielt hat. Er ist jetzt eher der Architekt, wenn man so will. Also ein bisschen zurückgezogen.
Passt ja auch zum Fortgeschrittenen, Alter. Mit 30 kann man sich langsam bis hin.
Und er nimmt die Rolle auch super an. Er muss natürlich mehr defensiv arbeiten. Aber er macht das auch richtig gut. Es wurde auch von Marquine schon öffentlich gelobt, dass er die leicht veränderte Rolle gut annimmt. Eine andere wichtige Stütze ist Pablo Sarabia. Der rechte Flügelstürmer, wenn man so will, im 3-4-3, hat schon fünf Tore und vier Assists. Also eine richtig, richtig starke Ausbeute. Und tatsächlich Andre Silva, der ja beim AC Mailand so überhaupt nicht stattfand, der sich da überhaupt nicht zurechtfand, wurde jetzt von Sevilla ausgeladen und hat in zehn Spielen schon sieben Tore geschossen. Der fühlt sich richtig wohl bei Sevilla.
Sehr schön. Auch erst 23 Jahre alt. Den hätte ich irgendwie älter geschätzt. Also da ist auch durchaus ein gutes Fundament gelegt.
Neben Andre Silva muss man auch Benyeder und Muriel hervorheben. Das ist das Sturmtrio quasi, die rotieren immer mal wieder. Und zu dritt sind sie die effektivsten Stürmer der Liga. Die drei Angrafe brauchen nämlich nur gut dreieinhalb Schüsse für ein Tor. Also sprich, Silva hat sieben Tore, Benyeder hat fünf, hat acht Tore und Muriel hat fünf Tore, die treffen, wie sie wollen. Nach Belieben quasi.
Das ist eine Effizienz, die lässt harter BSC vor Neid ablassen.
Genau, auch da kann man natürlich sagen, das wird jetzt nicht immer so bleiben, aber tatsächlich, die Stürmer sind effektiv. Das Mittelfeld arbeitet gut, das neue System greift. Das scheint einfach zu funktionieren aktuell bei Sevilla.
Nicht schlecht, und so landet man dann auf einem dritten Tabellenplatz. Und der liegt dann noch einen Platz vor Atletico, die uns deutschen Beobachtern noch etwas deutlicher vor Augen sind. Nicht nur wegen des großen Namens und der wichtigen Person dort, sondern vor allem auch wegen Hin- und Rückspiele gegen Borussia Dortmund. Jetzt haben wir das eine gesehen, das war ein 4 zu 0 in Dortmund, also ein 0 zu 4. Und jetzt das Rückspiele, das war ein 2 zu 0 Sieg zu Hause in Madrid. Wo würdest du denn die Leistungsmitte von Atletico ungefähr ansetzen? Liegt es genau in der Mitte, oder wie läuft die Saison bisher?
Im Endeffekt liegt es genau in der Mitte, wobei man sagen muss, dass das 4-0 von Dortmund kein 4-0 war. Ich war im Stadion beim Spiel, habe das Spiel gesehen. Das war ein sehr kurioser, komischer Spielverlauf. Das 1-0 von Dortmund, der abgefestigte Schuss von Witsel, war natürlich sehr glücklich, dass der reingeht. Auf der Gegenseite hat Saul mit einem Klassenschuss nur die Latte getroffen. Er müsste ja den Schuss von Saul reingehen. Dann sprechen wir entweder von dem Ausgleich zum 1-1, oder wenn man beide Tore wegkreuzt, steht es halt 0-0. Im Endeffekt war das das Leistungsvermögen der Mannschaften unentschieden. Dortmund hat dann mit jedem Schuss getroffen. Das war ja auch sehr, sehr krass, wie Dortmund war. Wie kalt schnäuzig sie da waren. Atletico hat sich da teilweise überrumpeln lassen, hatten aber eine sehr starke Druckphase, wo sie dem 1-1 sehr nahe waren, unter anderem der Latten-Treffer.
Ist das auch so die Perspektive, wie man es in Spanien gesehen hat, diese Niederlage?
Ja, die Sache ist, ein 4-0 sieht halt blöd aus. Das liest sich schlimm. Meist analysiert man Spiele vom Ergebnis her, leider muss man ja sagen. Dann sagt man 4-0 ist natürlich eine Schande, schlechte Leistung. Aber tatsächlich, dadurch, dass ich im Stadion war, so schlecht war die Leistung nicht. Die ist des Spieles hinten raus einfach runtergekippt. Aber normal geht so was maximal 2-1 für Dortmund aus. Und wenn man dann sieht, weil wir über Leistungsmittel gesprochen haben, sagen wir mal 2-1 in Dortmund, 2-0 daheim, da sind wir bei der Leistungsstärke Athletikos. Ich denke, sie sind mit Dortmund tatsächlich völlig auf Augenhöhe von der Leistungsstärke. Und in Dortmund hat halt einiges nicht geklappt. Aber ich glaube, so ein Spiel würde sich so nicht mehr wiederholen. Vor allem, weil es ja die höchste Niederlage unter Cholo Simeone war, die Athletico jemals kassiert hat. Also da sieht man mal, was das für ein Ausreißer war.
Ja, Wahnsinn, Wahnsinn. Allein die sechs Tore, die man jetzt erst nach elf Spielen in der spanischen Liga kassiert hat, zeigt das schon. Allein, wenn man da die vier draufrechnen würde, was das eben bedeutet für Athletico. Jetzt läuft es in der Liga, mir fällt es schwer, das einzuordnen. Fünf Siege, fünf Unentschieden, erst eine Niederlage. Das heißt, genauso häufig verloren wie Barcelona, aber eben durch die mehrere Unentschieden. Vier Punkte Rückstand und deswegen aktuell einen Tabellenplatz Vier. Wobei sich ab dem zweiten Tabellenplatz ist es kuschelig eng. Also das geht da nur um ein Pünktchen, wo man dann da steht. Wie würdest du denn die bisherige Saison von Athletico bewerten?
Also das ist tatsächlich Athletico wie es lebt und lebt, würde ich sagen. In Spanien, in La Liga. Die beste Abwehr natürlich wieder, wie immer. Muss man ja auch dazu sagen. Aber sie tun sich weiterhin schwer, Tore zu schießen. Vor allem aber schwer, gegen tiefstehende Gegner Torschancen herauszuarbeiten. Weil ihre Stärke ist halt die Defensive und das Zerstören des Spiels nach wie vor. Um da eben Nadelstiche zu setzen, umzuschalten, Gegenpressing zu haben. Aber das geht halt selten in einer Liga, wenn man über 38 Spieltage quasi 34 davon der Favorit ist. Ausgenommen Barca, ausgenommen gegen Real Madrid und ausgenommen vielleicht in Sevilla. Ansonsten sind sie halt einfach fast immer der Favorit. Sprich, sie müssen das Spiel machen. Und dadurch tun sie sich halt schwer. Vor allem, wenn der Gegner ein Underdog ist, der sich gerne mal hinten reinstellt. Da haben sie nach wie vor die meisten Probleme. Und das sieht man daran, dass sie zu wenig Tore schießen.
Bei den Schüssen aufs Tor liegen sie nur auf Platz 11 in der Liga. Also das verdeutlicht das ganz gut. Jetzt ist ja das Personal ja aber gleich gut geblieben. Und wurde ja mit Le Mans sogar noch verbessert auf dem Flügel. Was so ein bisschen dann die Frage darauf hinlängt, wie passen da Anspruch und Wirklichkeit zusammen? Sieht man das alles noch relativ gelassen bei Atletico? Oder wie ist da die Stimmungslage?
Also bezüglich des Kaders muss ich sagen, nicht nur ich, sondern auch viele andere Experten sehen das so, dass das der beste Kader ist, den Atletico je gehabt hat. Sie haben ja nicht nur Le Mans verpflichtet, unter anderem war Liverpool an ihm dran. Viele Teams waren ihm interessiert. Das war schon ein Coup, das sie ihm bekommen haben. Sie haben auch Jelsen Martins für den Flügel geholt. Vorne natürlich Grießmann Behalten, der ja vor dem Absprung zu Barca war, sich dann aber für Atletico entschieden hat. Diego Costa natürlich, der erst im Winter kam, ist jetzt endlich voll integriert, wenn man so will, hat jetzt wieder Rhythmus. Also sprich, in der Offensive sind sie eigentlich richtig gut besetzt, aber sie kriegen das nicht so richtig auf den Platz, was verschiedene Gründe hatte. Zum einen ist einfach Csolo Simeone nicht dafür bekannt, dass er ein gutes Offensivspiel aufziehen kann. Die Stärken von ihm sind einfach eher gegen den Ball. Auch sein Credo, seine Denke, sein Dogma ist eben auf Arbeiterfußball, Außenseiterfußball, Underdogfußball ausgelegt. Sie tun sich generell mit der Rolle schwer, der Favorit zu sein, den Ball zu haben. Dann sind natürlich die Spieler neu, Schelzen, Martins und Lemar. Die müssen natürlich erst integriert werden. Vor allem, weil Lemar ja auch bei der WM war. Also so was dauert. Sie haben jetzt viele offensive Spieler, aber das Spielsystem ist dann doch eher konservativer. Sie spielen jetzt ganz selten nur 4-3-3. Lemar spielt hauptsächlich im offensiven Mittelfeld, was ihn gut tut. Ich glaube, in Dortmund hat er auch offensives Mittelfeld gespielt, wenn ich mich täusche. Was ihn mehr Ballsicherheit gibt und mehr Kreativität. Aber so richtig in Torschancen und Tore um uns können sie es einfach noch nicht. Nach wie vor ist das die alte Problematik. Atletico mit Ball ist nicht das Gleiche wie Atletico ohne Ball.
Das hat man ja auch bei dem 2-0 ganz gut gesehen. Blitzsauber herausgespielt, das 2-0, eine Augenweide an Konter. Das war so Atletico, wofür es steht. Und das, wofür es nicht steht, das hast du ja gerade auch ein bisschen rausgearbeitet. Ja, dann vermute ich, wird man nicht so ganz zufrieden sein, wenn du jetzt sagst, bester Kader aller Zeiten. Und wir haben vorhin schon bei Barca drüber gesprochen. Ungewöhnlich viele Punkte schon abgegeben, nämlich drei Unentschieden, eine Niederlage. Das wäre die Möglichkeit für Atletico gewesen, da mal vorzulegen. Und so sind es aber vier Punkte Rückstand hinter Barcelona.
Aber es ist die Krux. Im Endeffekt über 38 Spieltage. Da muss man halt konstant auch die Punkte holen. Und mit Punkte meine ich natürlich die Siege gegen die Kleinen. Und daran scheitert es immer, dass sie wirklich ganz, ganz oben, also sprich auf Platz 1, vordrängen können, weil sie einfach zu oft immer mal wieder gegen kleine Punkte liegen. Auch jetzt wird er in der 90. Gegentor kassiert, in Leganes. Das Spiel war eigentlich fast schon gewonnen. Und dann haben sie einen Ausgleich kassiert, der ihnen natürlich wieder zwei Punkte kostet. Und so sind sie jetzt vier Punkte hinter Barca statt nur zwei.
Apropos die Kleinen, das ist die perfekte Überleitung, die du mir gebaut hast zum Tabell in Platz 5. Und da wird kleines Quiz, liebe Rasenfunk-Hörerinnen und Hörer. Wer liegt in La Liga auf Platz 5? Ja, ihr habt alle natürlich nicht recht. Deportivo Alaves, bzw. manche von euch werden es natürlich gewusst haben. Ihr verdammten Klugscheißer. Alaves auf Platz 5, was ist denn da los? Wer zur Hölle ist Deportivo Alaves?
Ja, wer zur Hölle ist Alaves? Alaves ist ein aufständisches, kleines, gallisches Dorf, wenn man so will. Und sie machen das Beste aus ihren Möglichkeiten. Sie sind garstig, sie sind widerständig, sie sind borstig. Und sie holen Punkte und hören nicht auf. Also im Endeffekt, wir sprechen über Trainer. Das ist so der rote Faden. Auch hier ist wieder der Trainer, der Schlüssel. Das muss man einfach sagen. Abelardo macht einen sensationellen Job. Es ist Alaves bester Saisonstart seit 2001. Das ist das Jahr, in dem sie das Finale des UEFA Cups erreichten. Also sie überperformen, aber sogar historisch gesehen sind sie sensationell gut. Und sie machen das auf interessante Weise, denn sie haben den wenigsten Ballbesitz der Liga mit 42 Prozent. Und, das ist richtig interessant, sie haben sogar die zweitschlechteste Passquote der Liga mit rund 70 Prozent. Aber sie machen unglaublich viel daraus. Auch Alaves ist, ähnlich wie Sevilla, sehr, sehr effizient. Also sie verteidigen tief. Sie beherrschen es, am 16. sich zu verbarrikadieren. Sie arbeiten gerne mit langen Bällen. Aber sie machen eine kleine Mannschaft mit den Mitteln, die sie zur Verfügung haben. Aber sie machen sehr, sehr viel daraus. Sie haben ja unter anderem zu Hause das große Real Madrid 1-0 geschlagen in der Nachspielzeit. Und dieser Sieg damals hiefte sie sogar auf Platz 1. Das ist jetzt richtig interessant. Sie waren zum dritten Mal in ihrer Historie erst Tabellenführer. Nach 1930 und 2010, wo sie zwei Wochen mal die Tabellenführung hatten. Also du siehst, sie sind sensationelle Überperformer. Das ist wirklich so eine kleine Feel-Good-Story, weil sie kaum berühmte Spieler haben oder keine auffälligen Spieler, wo du sagst, das ist ein richtiges Talent, auf das muss man achten. Sie bestechen durch Arbeitseifer, sie sind gut organisiert und kommen über Teamwork. Sie machen das Beste daraus.
Verrückt, ich glaube, du meinst 2001, weil 2010 waren sie in der dritten Liga, wenn ich richtig informiert bin.
Habe ich 2010 gesagt, ich meine natürlich 2001.
Genau, darauf wollte ich gerade noch zu sprechen kommen. Alaves an das UEFA Cup Europa League Endspiel, da konnte man sich noch so ganz dunkel vielleicht erinnern, aber danach, für mich und wahrscheinlich auch viele andere, verschwunden erst zwei Spielzeiten in der zweiten Liga, 2003 bis 2005, dann der Aufstieg direkt wieder runtergegangen, wieder zweite Liga, dann runter in die dritte Liga, vier Jahre in der dritten Liga, dann noch mal drei Jahre in der zweiten Liga und dann zur Saison 2016, 2017 aufgestiegen. Also Alaves wirklich lange von der Bildfläche verschwunden und jetzt dann dieser irre Erfolg. Hört sich allerdings ehrlich gesagt auch so ein bisschen an, Alex, als müsse man jetzt nicht unbedingt erwarten, dass das jetzt so weitergeht?
Also tatsächlich darf man oder sollte man bei Alaves sogar erwarten, dass es nicht so weitergeht, weil sie einfach überperformen. Ihre Stürmer brauchen nur rund vier Schüsse für ein Tor. Das ist ein sensationeller Wert, der sich normalerweise schwer so weiter durch oder der schwer aufrechterhalten bleibt. Im Schnitt schießen sie nämlich nur elfmal pro Spiel aufs Tor. Nur vier Teams schießen weniger aufs Tor. Also du siehst, sie machen aus wenig unglaublich viel. Wie gesagt, sie sind sehr gut organisiert, ein grundsolides, unbequemes Team. Also eher ohne den Ballarbeit als mit. Sie spielen mit zwei Ketten, sie spielen 4-4-2. Aber Lado bevorzugt ihn 4-4-2, weil er –das hat er auch so gesagt –weil er gerne über die Flügel angreift. Sprich, er postiert zwei Abwehrketten, eine Doppel-6 und dann eben die Angriffe über die Flügel. Das ist Johnny auf der einen Seite, oder Yoni auf der linken Seite. Der hat schon sechs Vorlagen, das sind die meisten der Liga, mehr als Messi. Auf dem rechten Flügel spielt Ibai Gomez, der hat schon drei Tore und eine Vorlage. Also die Flügelzange funktioniert hervorragend. Und genau, sie machen über ihr Konterspiel, über ihre Flanken, über ihre langen Bälle aus wenig viel. Aber normalerweise sollte das nicht so weitergehen. Also ich wäre überrascht, wenn es so weitergeht. Wir sind erst am 11. Spieltag.
Ja, das ist ja alles klar. Andererseits hat die Tabelle dann schon ein bisschen eine Aussagekraft. Wie ist das? Dann wird so etwas in Spanien dann auch richtig hochgefeiert, weil es auch so ein bisschen Ausbruch ist aus dem immergleichen, was man ja häufig gesehen hat gerade an der Tabellenspitze. Oder tickt man da eher so, dass man sagt, der Fußball ist zwar legitim, aber nicht schön anzuschauen. Und gerade in Spanien legt man ja doch noch einen anderen Wert auf Spielkultur als jetzt hierzulande zum Beispiel.
Grundsätzlich ist das so, tatsächlich. Dadurch sind die Schlagzeilen etwas gedämpfter, natürlich. Klar, weil sie eben Underdog-Fußball spielen und einen eher unspanischen Spielstil, kann man jetzt nicht sagen. Aber einfach etwas Außenseiterfußball. Klar, die Vereine, die eher im Mittelpunkt sind, sind dann die größeren Vereine per se grundsätzlich. Und wenn natürlich, auch wenn die schlecht spielen, da kommen wir ja gleich dazu, sind die eher im Fokus. Also, wie gesagt, Gallische Dorf. Ein bisschen so abseits des Rampenlichts.
Nein, wir haben sie jetzt erwähnt. Das heißt, mehr Rampenlicht wird es wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr geben.
Mehr Rampenlicht geht nicht, ja. Ganz interessant übrigens, weil du fragst, können die sich oben halten? Abelardo, der Trainer, wurde darauf angesprochen, ob ihre Ziele womöglich jetzt angepasst werden müssen.
Schön, dass es solche Fragen auch in Spanien gibt. Und was hat er gesagt?
Ob Europa League oder Champions League demnächst so ihr Ziel sein würden. Und da hat er gesagt, unser Ziel ist die Überlebens League. Also sprich, weiterhin den Abstieg verhindern.
Wir schauen weiter nur nach unten. Und jeder Kampf ist ein Kampf gegen den Abstieg. Das ist ja schön, dass manche Fußballkonstanten sich auch länderübergreifend wiederfinden lassen. Wir haben jetzt viel über Teams gesprochen, die auf den ersten sechs Tabellenplätzen liegen, nämlich ausschließlich über Teams, die dort liegen. Jetzt will ich zumindest noch zwei herausgreifen, die erstaunlich weit hinten stehen, nämlich zum einen der FC Valencia auf Tabellenplatz 15, und zum anderen der FC Villarreal auf Tabellenplatz 16. Was sind denn die Probleme in Valencia? Warum hat man erst einmal gewonnen in elf Spielen?
Um es auf den Punkt zu bringen, der Sturm ist zu harmlos. Ein Sieg, nur sieben Tore, das ist im Endeffekt schlicht zu wenig.
Immerhin auch nur neun kassiert.
Immerhin das, ja. Es ist ein bisschen paradox, wenn man auf die Namen der Stürmer schaut. Das ist schon ziemlich, eigentlich ziemlich saftig. Rodrigo, Gameru kam neu von Atletico, Santimina, ziemlich interessanter Jungstar, und Michi Batschoi, BVB-Knipser. Also eigentlich auf dem Papier sind das vier richtig gute Spieler, die sich eigentlich auch ergänzen sollten, weil Rodrigo eher hängend ist und so ein bisschen ein wuselnder spielerischer Stürmer. Batschoi ist eher so eine klassische Neun. Also eigentlich die Mischung müsste stimmen, aber die treffen einfach nicht.
Und kommen sie nicht in die Abschlusssituation oder verwerten sie ihre Chancen nicht?
Beides. Also sie brauchen fast 18 Schüsse für ein Tor, was schon ziemlich ineffektiv ist, muss man schon sehr sagen. Ja, Gameru und Batschoi haben nur ein Tor geschossen in elf Spielen. Das ist halt viel zu wenig. Auch Rodrigo nur ein Tor. Sie haben auch die Mischung noch nicht gefunden, dadurch, dass sie vier fast gleich starke Spieler haben, wenn du so willst. Es ist schwer zu sagen. Es gibt keine klare Nummer eins im Sturm oder kein Gesetz des Duos, sondern die wechseln sich ab. Wenn es bei dem einen Stürmer drei Spieler nicht läuft, kommt der andere rein. Dadurch kommen sie nicht in den Rhythmus. Dann kommt hinzu, dass Batschoi und Gameru neu sind. Das sind ja Neuzugänge. Sprich, die haben sich noch nicht so arg limitisiert. Das kann halt einfach mal passieren. Und so kommt eins zum anderen. Ein weiterer Grund ist die schlechte Form ihrer Außenspieler, Soler und Gedäsch. Gedäsch war ja letzte Saison vom PSG schon ausgeliehen. Den haben sie jetzt verpflichtet. Vor allem Gedäsch ist in sehr schlechter Form. Kommt überhaupt nicht in dritt bisher. Beide sind natürlich sehr jung. Soler und Gedäsch, das muss man dazu sagen. Erst 21, sprich da sind einfach Leistungsschwankungen normal. Aber so kommt eins zum anderen. Die Zulieferung in die Spitze stimmt nicht. Und dadurch treffen die Stürmer dann auch nicht.
Und dann die Effizienz vorne drin. Und so kommt es dann eben zu acht Unentschieden nach elf Spielen. Das ist dann sehr bemerkenswert. Einmal gewonnen, zweimal verloren, sieben zu neun Tore, elf Punkte. Und damit eben dieser Tabellenplatz 15. Und ein Pünktchen dahinter dann via Real. Die hätte ich jetzt auch weiter oben erwartet. Woran hakt es da?
Also, wenn ich noch kurz ein Wort zu Valencia sagen darf. Man muss auch sagen, sie hatten ein schweres Auftaktprogramm. Also sie haben gleich gegen Atletico begonnen, unentschieden gespielt. Dann war sie dann bei Überraschungsteam Espanyol direkt verloren. Dann ging es weiter gegen Betis, via Real, Celta Vigo, Real Sociedad und Barca. Also du siehst, das ist schon ein sehr, sehr happiges Auftaktprogramm.
Und in der Champions League konnte man sich die Beine vertreten gegen Juve, Manchester.
Also sprich, du siehst, da fehlen dann die Erfolgserlebnisse. Du hast ein schweres Auftaktprogramm. Du kommst nicht so in den Rhythmus. Dazu kommen die englischen Wochen. So kommt eins zum anderen. Und deswegen läuft das noch nicht so rund. Aber ich bin mir eigentlich sehr zuversichtlich, dass Valencia da unten bald herauskommen sollte, dass sie bald ihre Tore schießen soll.
Und bist du so ähnlich zuversichtlich auch bei Via Real?
Etwas weniger. Das hat damit zu tun, dass der Trainerstuhl wackelt. Also bei Valencia, die ja letztes Jahr eine starke Runde gespielt haben, die Champions League geschafft haben, da sitzt Marcelino, denke ich, fester im Sattel, als es Javier Calegia bei Via Real tut. Dessen Stuhl wackelt schon gehörig. Da gehen schon viele davon aus, dass er bald entlassen wird, wenn sich die Ergebnisse nicht bessern. Auch Via Real hat ähnliche Krankheitssymptome. Schlechte Ergebnisse führen zu wenig Selbstvertrauen. Die Neuzugänge finden sich noch nicht zu Recht. Oder laufen ihrer Form hinterher. Auch die haben ein Sturmproblem. Sie schießen zu wenig Tore. Die haben vor der Saison ihren Sturm komplett neu ersetzt. Gerardo Moreno für 20 Millionen von Espanyol geholt und Ekambi aus Frankreich von Orngeas, der 18 Millionen gekostet hat. Die haben richtig Geld in die Hand genommen. Die beiden treffen noch nicht. Moreno erst zwei Tore, Ekambi auch erst zwei Tore, Carlos Baccar, kennt man ja auch von Sevilla und Milan, erst ein Tor. Du siehst auch da, es hapert im Sturm. Und so kommt eins zum anderen. Kein Rhythmus, kein Automatismus, keine Tore, die natürlich dem Team auch irgendwie Luft verschaffen, Selbstvertrauen bringen.
Ich sehe schon, das ist ein bisschen das FC Schalke 04 Phänomen, das auch in anderen Ligen noch greift.
Ja, tatsächlich so ein bisschen. Also vor allem, wenn neue Spieler hinzukommen, wenn eine englische Woche hinzukommt, sprich, du musst rotieren, aber die Mannschaft ist ja noch gar nicht eingespielt, weil sie beispielsweise verändert wurde oder weil sie verletzungsbedingte Probleme hatte, weil auch das ist ein Problem bei Villareal. Im Maschinenraum der Mannschaft, wenn du so willst, also im zentralen defensiven Mittelfeld, fielen zwei Hau-Degen mit Javi Fuego und Bruno Soriano, beide sehr abgeklärt, sehr zweikampfstark, die eigentlich einer Mannschaft Stabilität geben sollten, aber die haben noch kein Spiel bestritten, weil sie verletzt sind. Die Spieler gehen einen natürlich ab, die Führungsspieler. Dann haben sie Rodri verloren an Atletico, den anderen defensiven Mittelfeldspieler. Sprich, du siehst genau im Zentrum, wo eine Mannschaft Stabilität braucht, da gehen ihnen die Spieler ab. Und die Charaktere. Genau, da haben sie zum Beispiel Caceres aus Argentinien geholt, der aber erst 21 ist und sich natürlich erst an den europäischen Fußball gewöhnen muss. Und so kommt eins zum anderen. Also, ja, die englischen Wochen helfen dann natürlich eine Mannschaft, die in der Krise ist nur bedingt, wenn sie dann wieder rotieren muss, wenn sie Donnerstag, weiß ich nicht, in Osteuropa ran muss. Also, hilft nicht.
Ja, das ist natürlich wahr. Das ist immer so eine zweischneidige Sache. Zum einen vergisst man das letzte Ergebnis sehr schnell, wenn man englische Wochen hat. Zum anderen hat man aber auch keine Zeit, Dinge einzustudieren und vielleicht versäumtes aus der Vorbereitung nachzuholen. Und du hast es ja schon angesprochen, die Gegner von Viereal sind eben in der Europa League, Glasgow Rangers, Spartak, Moskau und Rapid Wien. Da wissen wir auch, wen du gemeint hast, wenn es um den Osten geht, in dem man dann reisen muss.
Ja, also es sind auch da nicht die klangvollsten Gegner. Eine Mannschaft hat wenig Selbstvertrauen. Vielleicht kommen dazu dann Motivationsprobleme, weil die Europa League ist halt auch nicht für jeden das Maß aller Dinge. Wenn du dann zu Hause gegen Glasgow spielst und das Stadion halbleer ist, und du kein Selbstbewusstsein hast, keinen Rhythmus hast. Und auch da haben sie ja nicht gewinnen können. Also es war ja auch schon eine Überraschung gegen Glasgow. Sie haben das Spiel nicht nach Hause gebracht. Das Schalke-Syndrom, wenn du so willst.
Ein bisschen schon. Dann haben wir gelernt, Schalke ist nicht nur im Pott, sondern auch noch in La Liga. Alex, ich danke dir, dass du mir da ganz viele Fragen beantwortet hast. Und ich jetzt ein bisschen klüger bin, was die spanische Liga angeht.
Stichwort Fragen, darf ich abschließend eine Frage an dich stellen? Na klar. Es gibt nur drei Teams, also eine kleine Quizfrage für dich, aber vielleicht auch für die Zuhörer. Es gibt nur drei Teams, die mehr als 60 Prozent Ballbesitz und eine bessere Passquote als 85 Prozent haben. Wer sind die drei Teams?
Ich hätte jetzt natürlich den Tab offen, wo ich nur draufgehen würde, aber das wäre ungerecht. Passquote ist besser und Ballbesitz war über 60 Prozent?
Ballbesitz mehr als 60 Prozent und eine Passquote besser als 85 Prozent.
Okay, also Barca muss dabei sein.
Klar.
Sonst würde ich völlig vom Glauben abfallen. Real wird es schon mal nicht sein. Bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, dass die nicht mit dabei sind? Zonk ist mit dabei.
Real Madrid ist mit dabei. Und wer ist das dritte Team?
Das wird jetzt natürlich irgendwas ganz Interessantes sein. Ich weiß noch aus dem letzten Kurzpass, dass Celta Vigo eine sehr interessante Runde gespielt hat. Da würde ich jetzt einfach mal all in gehen und sagen, Celta Vigo.
Dann habe ich dein Geld leider gewonnen. Es ist nicht Celta Vigo. Es ist Real Betis, über die wir gar nicht gesprochen haben. Aber tatsächlich Betis.
Verrückt. Mit 8 zu 2 Toren, so viel Ballbesitz und eine so gute Passquote.
Eine ganz interessante Mannschaft. Einen ganz eigenen Stil. Am Ersten das, was quasi Barca, Pep Guardiola bei City oder zum Beispiel Sari, Maurizio Sari bei Chelsea spielen. Sehr viel Ballbesitz, sehr viel Positionsspiel. Sehr interessante Mannschaft. Aber auch die haben das Schalke-Syndrom. Gewinnen nicht, schießen keine Tore. Englische Woche.
Aber damit hast du noch rausgelassen, wer so ein bisschen der Hipster-Liebling der Liga ist. Das ist eben nicht aller was. Das können ruhig alle feiern. Aber bäh, die spielen mit langen Bällen. Und wie geil ja. Nein, wir schauen uns Real Betis an und sagen, ach, das riecht ein bisschen nach Guardiola.
Es gibt einen wunderschönen Hashtag auf Twitter. Always watch Betis. Der war letztes Jahr schon trending, wenn du so willst. Unter den Hipstern war Betis das Team to watch. Dieses Jahr sind sie etwas weniger, weil sie keine Tore schießen. Weil sie einfach Probleme haben. Aber zum Ansehen sind sie tatsächlich klasse. Also wenn man so ein bisschen Fable hat für Ballbesitz, für schönes Spiel, für Positionsspiel, für aktives, aktiven Fußball, für all das.
Schlagen sie denn viele Flankenwarte? Das darf ich ja jetzt nachgucken. Das darf ich jetzt wieder hier auf meinen Tab gehen. Das ist für mich gerade das wichtigste Thema. Werden viele Flanken geschlagen.
Warum magst du Flanken denn so sehr?
Ich mag Flanken nicht, weil sie so wahnsinnig ineffizient sind. Also außer man spielt sie in einen Strafraum, der sehr gut besetzt ist. Aber ansonsten, ich habe einfach zu viele schlechte Flanken in meinem Leben gesehen. Und seitdem ich dafür mehr drauf achte, egal.
Bin ich bei dir. Deswegen always watch Betis, weil die mögen, wenn Flanken dann eher als diagonaler Seiten wechseln, was ja so gesehen keine Flanke ist, weil es ja eine Spielverlagerung ist, wenn du willst. Aber tatsächlich sind am ehesten das die Flanken, die sie schlagen, eben einfach als Stilmittel, um das Spiel zu verlagern, um sich eine andere Ausgangsposition zu verschaffen. Also du siehst viele interessante Dinge bei Betis, kann ich jedem nur ans Herz legen. Das ist das Hipster-Team.
Okay, sehr gut. Dann haben wir das auch noch mit reingenommen. Ja wunderbar, sehr schön. Das war Alex Truica, der genauso auch bei Twitter heißt. Alex Truica, Alex, ich danke dir sehr, dass du mal mit dabei warst.
Danke nochmal für die Einladung. Es war mir eine Ehre. Sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Das freut mich noch umso mehr. Mir auch. Vielen Dank euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Wenn ihr den Rasenfunk unterstützen wollt, dann könnt ihr das tun unter rasenfunk.de//unterstützen. Und solltet ihr schon registrierte Supporter sein unter rasenfunk.de//rsc, dann warten Sticker auf euch. Guckt mal in euer Mailfach oder registriert euch neu und schreibt mir. Dann klären wir das. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Wir hören uns nach dem nächsten Bundesligaspiel.
Ciao.